afternoon everybody and welcome to cloud
on air live webinar series from Google
cloud we're hosting a live webinar
series every Tuesday so you can check
the agenda and see a topic that's used
for you and join my name is sandy Jones
and today I'm gonna be walking you
through engaging meetings making them
easy accessible and everywhere
throughout the session you can actually
ask questions using the platform below
I've got some people ready and waiting
to answer your questions and at the very
end I'm going to choose a few to just do
in a Q&A session and answer live so
let's get started
like I said I want to talk to you today
about meeting experiences and you know
at Google video conferencing is a
crucial tool for how we do business if
you walk the halls in Google you'll see
every meeting room no matter how small
or large
there's faces in the room but also faces
on the screen and we produce I think 10
years of video conference every single
day and it's become a valuable tool
because it's allow us to build our
culture be more agile and more
collaborative and so that's what I
really want to talk about today and you
know it really begins with this changing
enterprise and I don't think that's any
revelation that enterprises are always
constantly under an evolution but I
think the current evolution that we're
in really started back in the 90s and
started with the desktop computer when
the price point hits such a level and
the memory and processing power hit a
level suddenly every desktop was enabled
with a computer it really skyrocketed
the productivity an individual user
empowered our knowledge workers to
really work on their own to an
incredible capacity jump forward about
ten years with the rise of the internet
and we saw a new trend starting to take
over and drive that evolution within the
enterprise and that was really two
pieces actually it's a rise of the cloud
computing within the internet
applications that were just served up
over the internet taking advantage that
distribution mechanism and the rise of
mobile devices a supercomputer in your
pocket so suddenly everybody had a
computer in their pocket they were
networked together to applications and
that effect really has accelerated the
productivity today of anyway the
organizations that have embraced these
types of transformations and we've seen
the impact that this second digital
transformations had on the industry if
you look at the S&P 500 that's kind of
an indicator of churn within business it
used to be that once you made
the sp500 like in the 50s you'd stay on
there for upwards of 60 years not a lot
of change there because companies it
took so much work to get there fast
forward to modern times in 2011 that was
cut down to 18 years even today we've
seen in a matter of weeks companies can
be in and out of that sp500 and it's
because of their ability to kind of shed
a lot of the things you needed to build
up over time in the past and so when you
look at how long it took to get to 50
million users for the telephone that was
a 75 year span mainly because they had
to build infrastructure make the various
telephone companies playing nice
together and really get to that point
where was accessible to 50 million users
you see there's a demarcation point
there in the middle cloud innovation
really that's where we've been able to
shed a lot that infrastructure had seen
the rise of these applications that hit
the 50 million user mark in almost what
peers like no time at all
Spotify made it in eight years Netflix
and seven Twitter took that down two
months and more recently pokemons go hit
that target in 19 19 days so a real
increase our acceleration in the churn
within businesses and really what that
meant is that organizations now need to
think differently they need to embrace
this digital disruption that's happening
and so they're turning to companies like
Google the digital natives that have
built tools that were purposely meant
for the cloud and so we're working with
some of the the top companies on the for
cloud 100 list and bringing these tool
sets to them and you may be familiar
with some of the companies here a lot of
them maybe even predated that telephone
technology I was talking about Colgate
Palmolive a company on the S&P 500
that's been able to go through this
digital transformation with us it's
impacted their culture change the way
they work remotely giving them access to
recruit and retain talent that's more
used to working in this digital world
and really more importantly it's
increased level of collaboration within
their organization and they've done that
like I said by embracing the tools and
the G suite set there's kind of four
main areas within their creative tools
and empower your knowledge workers to
create and share content connection
tools that bring your company together
like video conferencing or email and
chat and then access tools that turn a
Google search into a search of your
entire enterprise corpus and allow you
to surface materials that you maybe
would never find in the past lastly that
all needs to be managed
controlled and secure way by our IT team
and we've given the cloud tools to do
that but today I want to focus in on on
two key elements wanting to create side
and one in the connect side and that's a
jam board and Google Hangouts meet so
the jam board you can see my partner in
crime here behind me that's a digital
whiteboard that's really bringing the
whiteboard experience into the the
digital age and then hang out to meet a
video conferencing tool that really
turns any endpoint a phone or a browser
into a video conferencing tool and you
know the impact that it has is
incredible we just sort of focus on the
transformation within your meeting rooms
and it's it's actually two pieces
technological and cultural and I think
that second one often gets missed
companies look at the technology
investment and forget to see that
there's also a cultural impact and so
it's not just about swapping out the
tech in order to provide this better
experience you need to transform the
culture of your business and the to go
very hand-in-hand what you end up with
is a more engaged community of users
that communicate more they become highly
more productive and collaborative and
that results in an agile business that
can change based on market or
competitive forces that are always kind
of trying to adapt to and so to make up
this toolkit like I said there's kind of
the de Chambord and the hangouts meet I
want to talk about it but there's
actually two elements to each of those a
software side and the hardware side the
software side first we'll talk about
hangouts meet that takes advantage of
that cloud computing to deliver a high
quality video conference experience from
really anywhere in the world of course
in the boardroom we want a little bit
more of a professional enterprise grade
video conference and so we've come out
with the meet hardware kit which is
maximize the experience inside here and
your business infrastructure now we felt
that though the whiteboard was a
critical piece of the ideation process
in business in the past but it kind of
failed to move into the future so we
brought it there that's what the jam
board is a digital whiteboard that
connects users just together via the the
board itself or via a series of
applications that enable you to create
ninety-eight from anywhere that you are
now the result of implementing these
tools is kind of fourfold and I want to
talk about each one a little bit
separately I've harped on the culture of
collaboration we're going to talk about
why that's so critical to really focus
in
on creating a face-to-face experience at
some of the benefits that you get from
that I also want to talk about
productivity everywhere making your
users productive no matter where they
are in the world or what they're doing
or what time of day next we'll take a
look at building consensus driving your
organization in the same direction and
driving them towards creative solutions
in the less debate more create section
and then lastly I want to talk about the
enterprise-grade nature of this the
quality of the tools themselves and your
ability to manage it as an IT
organization let's start with the
culture of collaboration let's be honest
people really do not like going to
meetings if you've been in any meeting
that was just a conference bridge you
look around the table
everybody's multitasking we found that
up to 60 percent of people are actually
multitasking in a traditional conference
bridge and you know it's just not a
productive time in terms of meeting
itself workers find they have too many
meetings and half of those they've
they've identified as wasteful and the
fact is they're just gonna be more
meetings this isn't going away there
isn't more meetings in there or less
meetings there was yesterday there's
more and so as our time gets consumed
more more meetings we need to make these
more productive and so Google approached
this as a whole new meeting experience
we wanted video conference to be the
always thing you did there is no reason
to not turn on that camera and engage in
an interpersonal way so we created
hangout meet and it's you know we
rebuilt it from the ground up we
improved the media quality so the audio
and video is much higher than what you
saw in the initial hangouts we made it
easy to record and share the content
using drive integrations we've increased
the size of the attendees up to 50
participants we're gonna continue to
push that boundary in the future and
provided tools like in meeting context
and chat integration so that that
in-room experience is as good as when
your remote and really what this is done
is allow you to focus on the meeting and
so it's brought people back into the
meeting instead of multitasking and you
know doing other things you have
presence people will have to be a part
of that meeting there's a social
contract built into being face to face
not only that I'm getting a lot more
information via body language and even
be able to kind of cross language
barriers almost because I'm able to see
the emotions and the the kind of the
face reactions of the people involved
but actually the most important impact
is one that we actually discovered
through a lot of research so Google
spent a lot of time figuring out what
makes a team successful and actually you
might see a hyperlink there if you
google rework and Google you'll come
across a series of studies that we did
just trying to improve our organization
we've shared that out to the rest of the
world and one study in particular like I
said was focused on making successful
teams and what we found time and again
was it wasn't having common goals or
having strong leadership or clear tasks
defined with timelines it was something
called psychological safety that's what
made a team successful and what we mean
by that is the ability to feel safe in
sharing your ideas taking risks and
really working as a team that's
something that's built into a video
conference culture and it can't be a
culture that meets on video conference
once a week for that weekly meeting it's
a company that meets all the time on
video conference that uses video
conference as the go-to way to
communicate when you're not in the same
room and creates an experience like
you're in the same room no matter where
you are and so I think that's something
to really highlight there's subtle
psychological benefits and social
benefits that come out of this that
really make this an impactful cultural
transformation and with all of those you
begin to graphs the idea of business in
real time this is something again that
kind of came with the rise of cloud
computing these interconnected systems
they were able to update databases in
real time well that's now moved on to
the getting things done part of the
business and it's being able to jump on
a video conference and tackle a problem
without having to pre establish when
that conference is going to be and and
set that up in a tool somewhere or be in
that meeting room where we have the
video conference unit set up it's about
just jumping in and getting it done it's
about doing real time on jam board so I
can share my ideas and collaborate in
real time I can fix maybe something that
somebody made a mistake on you know
before I was trapped behind the video
conference tool now I can just update
that on my jam board they see the impact
on theirs so it's about just increasing
the acceleration of how you get things
done now of course once you're doing
this you need to be able to do this
everywhere the way you drive these tools
to be part of your culture is by making
everybody enabled to use them no matter
where they are if they're at home on the
road or anywhere else and and the fact
is employees are more
or remote as we go on you know we've
sort of done the math and by 2020 half
of your workforce is gonna be
contributing remotely whether that's on
client sites or you know touching in
from their vacations not something you
want to do but something more and more
we have to do in this ever connected
world so we need the tools to support
that so that things don't go off the
rails when we're not physically in the
office and that's really what we've
tried to do with these these conference
tools make them super easy to join from
a browser or tablet or a smartphone make
it as simple as tapping a URL to hop in
in the meeting providing a dial in code
at no extra charge that you can dial
into the meeting through a phone it's
part of our Enterprise Edition and then
tying that all into the calendaring
tools so that when I book a room I go in
there the the meetings already in that
room anybody
added to the calendar gets access to the
meeting gets access to the content
that's part of that meeting really just
trying to make it as easy as possible
and and as beneficial for all your users
we worked with the Wyoming Medical
Center and they leverage this technology
to reach out to their clinicians in
remote areas connect those to neuro
surgeons and cardiologists and allow
them to spread knowledge way beyond the
walls of their organization no longer
did they have to bring them in for a
kind of knowledge transfer sessions in
the moment when they need to answer they
could jump on a hangout right from their
mobile phone and be connected to these
experts and that's really what it takes
having a suite of tools that's good on
the go but also in the boardroom bridges
that gap between remote and on location
so with all these tools in place we've
got everybody collaborating and working
together they're productive no matter
where they are the result is this idea
of consensus but what we found was when
we got the videoconferencing so
successful at Google we'd left behind
the whiteboard and the whiteboard had
become this broken tool it worked great
for the people in the room still work
like it just did pick up the marker and
go but for somebody remote on the
videoconference
they'd have to play the broken telephone
game to get that picture corrected or
maybe just never got to add their ideas
whatsoever and you know we tried hacking
a solution I'm sure everybody's done a
few of these things maybe taking a
picture of the whiteboard and email that
around everybody or pointed a camera
from a video conferencing unit at the
whiteboard hopefully those remote people
could see my
grachi writing on the board or tried
using Docs and sheets which are
outstanding form of collaboration but
are structured and kind of put you in a
box and don't allow that freeform
creativity of the jam board or of a
whiteboards today and so that's why we
built the jam board we we spent a lot of
time building both the hardware and the
software to make this a wonderful
whiteboard esque experience it allows
you to contribute anywhere the way you
want and it really engages your team to
work better no matter where they are
located and and the first thing you're
gonna notice whiteboards kind of a
journey in my mind you you kind of walk
up in the first thing you notice is how
smooth it reacts to the marker how much
it feels like I actually picked up a
marker and wrote on the board but then
you start to notice that this this Jam
board does a lot more than my whiteboard
used to it corrects my writing when I
write messy it doesn't need to be taking
a picture of or written do not erase
because it auto-saves every time I do
something it's tied to rich content so I
can bring images out of a browser from
my drive and it has machine learning to
correct my crappy drawings and turn them
into something a lot more appealing it's
connected together so one jam board
connects to another jam board if I'm
working with somebody on the other side
of the continent I can see what they're
drawing in real time they can see what I
draw in real time it works on mobile
devices so it doesn't matter how I'm
connecting in I'm still sharing that
experience in I da ting never missing a
creative moment it works great with
hangouts so if I have people that aren't
near jam board maybe don't use any
Google applications whatsoever they can
click that hangouts meet link jump in a
hangout see the jam board session and
provide therefore verbal feedback so a
great pairing of the jam board and the
hangouts meet if they're paired in a
room they're gonna work in sync to join
the meeting together and maybe most
importantly that connection to 2g suite
so G suite offers a lot of really great
collaborative editors we've added jam
board to that mix but we've also added
those editors to jam board so I can
bring in a doc sheet or slide to my jam
board session start to annotate add my
notes really collaborate around that
content as well bridging that workflow
gap
lastly I want to talk about the the
enterprise-grade nature of this and we
spent a lot of time really focusing in
on how to make these tools the the
enterprise experience not only the users
needed but that IT needed to manage and
support them and so you know we added a
lot of enterprise grade functionality we
we took advantage of Google's robust
security posture and really took
advantage of our scale as well and let's
start with the scale question and we
ride on the same network and data center
infrastructure as YouTube so we're able
to take advantage of that global scale
to deliver high quality video
conferencing around the world we've
integrated this in with G suite in a few
different ways beyond just the the
integrations I just talked about but it
begins with your calendar so when I
start countering something it will
suggest rooms for me based on the
location of the users then it will
automatically add a link into a hangouts
meat session it'll automatically add
that to the room I put it in so I just
have to tap and go really just makes
that a seamless frictionless experience
for my users when they walk into the
room the jam will last to join the
meeting if it's paired with the device
if I decide to record that session I tap
a button and that's dropped into my
drive for me later on and all of that
the devices the experience for the users
and the licensing is all managed inside
of the admin console in the cloud so I
can easily access and make changes in
real time let's take a look at some of
the hardware itself so this is our our
hangouts meat hardware kit comes with
four pieces the chrome box which you see
on the left there a camera depending on
the size of the room we'll talk about
that in just a second a speaker mic and
a touchscreen to control everything
about the meeting so this would be your
in room setup and let's just talk a bit
about each one of those this small
hudley camera is really powerful it
packs a big punch for a little camera
has a wide field of view it's ideal for
smaller rooms that you have so capture
everybody in the room not only that it
has onboard machine learning so we put
machine learning into the camera which
currently enables us to crop and and
zoom to get the right perspective for
the number of people in the room and one
power even more machine learning as we
move forward and develop this out
further we've also got a large room kit
as well that comes with a high quality
PTZ logitech camera
offers 10x zoom and hide HD and also a
wide field of view there the speaker mic
took a lot of engineering and effort to
create a state of the art noise
suppression and echo cancellation
experience in the room but also allows
you to fully control the room from any
one of the devices you can daisy chain
these together with a single cable to
extend it out for large configurations
all the updates to this are passed down
right from the chrome box so I don't
even have to manage this as we come up
with better algorithms for that noise
suppression they're gonna automatically
get updated into that device and the
center with all those a touchscreen and
this is a really great experience for
your end users they don't have to worry
about how they connect into their
meeting they just walk in tap their
meeting on the calendar there and that's
what's happening it's being fed from the
calendar booking right in the room I can
see my meeting tap and go want to record
the meeting I tap it once more want to
call a phone I can dial a phone number
out from there bring up the chat that's
going on for the meeting all sorts of
functionality built right in there easy
for your users to engage in we started
to qualified peripherals program
recently to just increase the amount of
customization you can do to your rooms
adding different cable sets some
different camera options and really just
trying to give you more options in terms
of how you build out those more complex
or unusual rooms that you're facing on
the jam board side we spent a lot of
time building out the quality of the
screen so that the touch was really
responsive but also you get this big
screen for a low price point so that
took a lot of the the engineering effort
was to make this and easily engage Abul
feel like a fluid whiteboard but we also
took some time and effort into this
stylus to make sure you didn't have to
have batteries in here so nothing would
get in the way of you hosting your
meeting running your meeting all of this
is managed like I said through that
centralized administration console so
we're bringing that all into the Google
admin console where you manage your G
suite users today and we're providing
you with analytics that tell you things
about your resource allocation and help
you manage cost control as well so now
what I want to do is actually show you a
little bit about the jam board and see
what that experience is like but just a
quick reminder that these tools really
do a few different things for
organization first
to change the culture of how you guys
work together one of the phenomena I
have it Google is when I've worked with
somebody for through a few video
conferences and then I end up meeting up
in person and nine times out of a ten I
forget that it's the first time I've
actually met this person because the
video conference experience feels so
much like getting to know them it just
creates a tighter work relationship
changing that culture organization is
that is one of the top benefits that you
get from using the Hangouts meeting at
the jam board tools but it also makes
you productive any everywhere if you
need to be remote for a day you can
easily still interact with your
co-workers or your customers or your
partners using hangouts meet as if
you're in the same room those in
together drive consensus put your
company on the same page and it can all
be managed through enterprise-grade
toolset to make sure you're safe and
secure and in compliance so with that
let's let's move to the Jan board now
I'm kind of lucky today because I have
an Android enabled laptop and I have a
jam board here behind me so you guys are
gonna kind of see a couple of ways then
I can interact with both devices at once
I'm gonna jump into my jam board on the
screen here so that you can kind of see
what it's like when I'm editing and and
see some of the editing tools that are
built into it and all that sort of stuff
so I'm gonna do a little bit drawing on
the left here you probably can see I've
got a whole set of tools and I can kind
of flip those around really easily it
gives me a lot of power to do different
sort of interactions with the board so
I'm gonna be using that a lot I've also
got my friendly undo so if I ever mess
anything up I can just tap that a couple
times and it takes me back to where I
was now I want to talk to you about the
collaborative nature of Jan board
because to me that's the true power of
this tool the fact that it does the the
cool white boring stuff is is great and
awesome but really where it gets its
legs in my mind is when it starts to be
a collaborative tool but and we designed
it to be easy and accessible and what I
mean by that is you shouldn't have to go
through training to use a jam board
first time I saw a jam board actually
was bring your kids to work day and it
was amazing to watch these these eight
and nine year olds run up to the jam
board grab one of the stylists and start
marking up the board right away grabbing
images off the web putting funny
mustaches on people and just
showed me how easily and approachable
this device was really from and also
from anywhere because then when you
start to connect the jam boards together
you start to see that clabber nature now
you may have noticed that the jam board
was fixing my writing as we went that's
part of the machine learning that's
built into the tool so I was using
handwriting recognition to take my messy
kind of doctor's writing and turn that
into something legible for everybody to
read really cool aspect of the jam board
but I also have a few other tools I want
to show off just while we're here I can
lasso things each one of these is an
object that I can then move around in
this case I'm just gonna kind of shrink
that and put it up in the corner so have
that ability to reconfigure the board
very unlike a whiteboard I don't have to
erase and redraw everything I could just
move things around same with this
picture here in the middle I'm just
gonna move it down a little bit now like
I said I want to talk about the way to
use jam board as a collaborative tool as
extension of do the collaboration you're
doing in G suite and other tools today
and really when you see that sort of
aspect of jam board best is when you
bring a second jam board into the mix so
I've added a second picture of my jam
board there on the screen and if you
notice behind me you can see in real
time the jam boards updating what's
going on and so when I have two Jam
boards together I can connect them and I
begin to mirror what's happening on one
Jam board with the other so that means
that if I'm on one coast and I'm working
with somebody maybe I'm in California
I'm in New York today I can share ideas
so maybe I'm drawing the next great idea
for Google on the board they can jump in
add their ideas extend my idea correct
my idea and really turn this into a
reality
now you may see on the bottom of the
screen right now the machine learning is
trying to process and figure out what it
is I was actually drawing it shows a
light bulb I can just tap that picture
on the bottom and it's now fixed up my
messy drawing and again made it more
legible I'm a little surprised to even
thought that was a light bulb because it
was very terrible but you can see the
power of the machine learning to just
take an unrecognizable kind of chicken
scratch and turned it into something
impactful so like I said the power of
the jam boards is when you can
than together but what if you're not in
a room with a jam board what if you're
on the road somewhere well we've
provided a complete toolkit of
applications so I might want to use that
on my mobile device my phone or a tablet
or maybe I'm going to be connecting via
my laptop let's take a look at each one
of those use cases a little bit
separately so with the phone it's maybe
not the ideal space to drawing a little
tricky limited real estate but is a
great place to id8 still I can still see
everything that's going on on the jamb
board right from my phone and I do have
the ability to also add content to the
jam session and one of the ways that I
like best is by leveraging sticky notes
and a very popular way of solving
problems today is called human oriented
design and it leverages sticky notes
very intensely you kind of place them on
quadrants and prioritize problems and so
if I have a great idea I can just type
that on my sticky note and add that
right in the jam session and now I have
another asset on the screen which is my
sticky note and let's just put that down
there and I'll just kind of show it just
gonna go right from my phone into that
jam session and if you're familiar with
human oriented design sometimes it's a
little bit of a challenge to get
everybody together for that session or
to get everybody in front of the board
because maybe some people a little shy
or they're just too much going on this
allows me to use my phone as that
mechanism for participating in the jam
session a really powerful way of
extending that now on my tablet I have
even more functionalities so the tablet
actually does everything that my jam
board does in the palm of my hands and
so I'm able to put content onto the jam
board but also see what's going on I
basically have a miniature Jam board and
not only that but I actually don't even
need the jam board at all I can have a
jam session directly with somebody on a
mobile device maybe another tablet or a
phone and I can even push stuff out
somebody on a laptop on the laptop I can
use a jam viewer to see what's going on
in the jam session I can also join maybe
a video conference and share my screen
to share that Jam out that way
now since we're talking about sharing
our jam sessions let's add a little bit
more content and this is where the rich
media starts to come into play I've got
a couple tools here on the left-hand
side that allow me to grab images from
the web I'm gonna grab a picture of the
hangouts logo and I can just use that
image browser to drag images right onto
the screen so there I've just dragged
that hangouts logo onto my jam session
but I also have a regular web browser
let's look up hangouts meet hardware tap
that link there takes me to the web page
I could scroll down maybe crop out a
piece of that web page for marking up
and annotating and now I have that on
there
it's just position these a little bit
and so like I said before hangouts meet
and jam board are great partners
together from I can join any meet as a
participant right from the the jam board
so that means I can share my screen in I
can share video into the Hangout I can
really participate in that hangout
remotely right from the jam board but
more importantly I can share that
ideation in that creation with any other
users obviously these two can connect as
well and just brings everyone together
onto the same page in the same room
lastly I want to talk a little bit about
G suite integration I can bring up my
Google Docs sheets and slides in Drive
go into a folder maybe grab a document I
want to work on put it down there in the
corner then I just double tap that
document and I can drag pages off gonna
grab the front page and then let's just
get rid of this piece here and notice I
can just drag stuff down to the bottom
to get rid of it so I've dragged a page
out of my dock and I can use that to add
to my jam session right from my phone or
from a tablet and we've used mobile
devices quite intelligently to act as a
second factor authentication to ensure
that you don't accidentally
leave your drive open on a jam session
and walk away from the jam board so
think of that device as a way of
securing your content personally to you
so I grab my lasso here let's just
select everything on the board and
shrink it down a little bit because the
other factor I want to point out is that
all of this stuff is stored in the cloud
and that means a few things first
it means I get to take advantage of all
the sharing built into Google right I
could can add people to my jam remove
people and really control the access to
that it also means I get autosave every
time I enter back with the board and you
see got my messy writing wrong there
rarely does that I can just stroke that
out rewrite it or even correct
individual letters if I want but the
point I was trying to make there was I
get the autosave functionality every
interaction I have with the jam board
automatically saved the cloud I don't
have to take a picture of that anymore I
also get unlimited space that means that
if I run out of space on one Jam I can
just pop open the top there create a new
tile maybe drag some content there and
begin my next session so hopefully you
saw a little bit about how the jam board
comes together show you on here see how
it connects people allows you to create
with partners in real time and really
how it brings that whiteboard into the
video conference sort of digital
generation that's really all I wanted to
go over you guys today but we're gonna
move the Q&A session I know you guys
have been asking questions throughout
the session so we're gonna take a minute
just kind of gather those up and then
I'll be right back to answer a few of
those
you
all right and we're back for the Q&A
session so I've got a few questions here
coming in from my team that have been
looking at your questions on the
platform just gonna answer them right
from the board here and so first
question I'm gonna grab here is what if
I want to share my jam session we've
taken advantage of the sharing
mechanisms within Google so it uses
exact same sharing paradigms I simply
pop open this side panel I can add
people to the jam session remove people
if I wanted to if I want to get rid of
Chris here I just hit the X and I can
add anyone else we also have the ability
to join Jam board to jam board just
using this little shortcode so that's
another way you could add people in
effect if they were in front of a jam
board like that so great question thank
you is the jam board available in
European markets yes it is we have londa
we launched in the UK last year we've
recently announced our launch within
Denmark France Netherlands Spain and the
Nordics so Sweden Finland and I think I
said everyone there Norway thank you so
the answers that more to come on that in
the future as well
how can Hangouts meet and jam board work
together so Hangouts meet is basically
accessible right from that same side
panel so I could connect into a meeting
I just use the 10-digit code and notice
there's actually if you probably can't
see it out there but there's a little
camera here there's a mic built into the
board so I could actually participate in
hangouts meet right from the board using
this camera or with this little toggle I
can present what's on the jam board into
the meet they're really easy to use
should be familiar to any hangouts meet
user when they get on the jam board
let's take this one is there a record
and playback feature very commonly asked
for feature requests you know we're
working on this one and it definitely
will be coming down the road but right
now the kind of workaround is to join a
meet session and then record that way
and you can see how the ideas came to to
pass or it came to into creation let's
see here
when will we be able to interact and
modify Jam on the Chrome browser that is
it coming soon as well
we're diligently working on this one
this is probably the number one request
we've gotten and you know there's some
some logic behind this we just felt that
this wasn't the way to drop
if anybody's tried to draw the mouse it
is not the type of user experience that
really works out for people so we
intentionally went for things that could
take advantage of a stylus or could at
least support better drawing and we felt
the phone and the tablet were the right
devices for that the phone for the
sticky noting and the tablet for finger
drawing and that's our thing we are
going to be releasing an editor for the
browser we want to make sure we do that
in the right way that takes advantage of
the form factor that is a laptop or
desktop computer can the jam board app
work without a jam board hardware ie
app on a tablet tablet yes absolutely
we initially thought hey this is just
going to be a tablet application we
built the whole jam board application
and every single person was saying I
wish this was bigger and so it led us to
build the jam board because we kind of
needed that as a companion to the tablet
so this was the first use case it
absolutely works tablet to tablet phone
to phone or however you want to connect
in id8 are there simple ways to connect
multiple people to the jam at once I
kind of showed this a little bit but I
just want to reiterate a couple thing
because there's multiple ways to connect
jams and I showed a couple here so I
have the idea or the ability I mean to
join or start a broadcast which means
that I can basically just give another
jam board user a code they can tap that
into their jam session and get that
mirroring going I can add people so
they'll now have the ability to jump
into the jam but also right from my
phone I can actually locate nearby
boards and throw my jam on to that board
from my phone so just using a Bluetooth
connection I'm able to throw a jam that
I have onto the board it will just ask
for a little acceptance and away I go
how often does hangouts meet Hardware
update is that a manual update it is
definitely not a manual update I do not
know the frequency of the update so I'll
have to
follow up on that if somebody on my
answer crew knows they can just throw a
sticky note up but but it does update
over-the-air so we push out the update
to the devices themselves and one of the
really powerful elements of that is it
also includes qualified peripherals so
if your speaker mic needs updated with
firmware we can push that right into the
chrome box and right through the wire to
that speaker mic meaning you don't have
to take care of anything you just let
that work on its own am I able to use
any of the existing equipment with HMH
so this is kind of a case-by-case basis
it's hard to kind of give it an overall
overarching answer we would recommend
using it with the equipment that it
comes with but we've found that a lot of
speakers and and and mics and even
cameras will work with the the kits you
just kind of have to try that out
yourself and see if it works but in many
cases you're able to swap in different
devices and we are working diligently to
expand that qualified peripherals
program to include and compass more
options that way last one is there a
demo or trial period for HMH well
there's a couple things I'd say to this
we don't have an official trial or demo
program at Google this time it's
something we've discussed and are
working on and thinking about but I
definitely reach out to your account
executive and we can discuss what what
the options are but the nice thing about
HMH is you don't actually need anything
more than a browser or a mobile device
to try out the experience so you can try
this without all the hardware see if it
works for you as sort of based on the
functionality and then decide if the
hardware is some direction you want to
go in so that's it for the questions
really appreciate everybody taking the
time today to join us thank you for
tuning the cloud on air please remember
we're hosting these live every Tuesday
hopefully you can join next week like I
said check the agenda there's a whole
bunch of different topics you'll
definitely find something of interest to
you thanks again take care